so in 1945 there was a sense that there
was really a new world to build because
the past world that this as it had
essentially disappeared
I think in 1989
because things went so smoothly which is
a very good thing
we felt that with this was just an
expansion of the world that we of the
world of democracy that existed in the
western part of Europe before 1989. we
thought we confused what was the
collapse of an exhausted regime the
Soviet Union and communism we confuse it
with the Triumph of democracy
and that was wrong and because of that
we began we had a kind of retrospective
approach to things the EU we thought the
first the most important thing was to
Germany was going to be bigger so the
first important thing was to prevent
Germany from being dominant so we did
good things we did the Euros but we
didn't think of the European Union in
its relationship to the rest of the
world we still saw it as a kind of
internal project which is a big mistake
with Russia
much is made of the enlargement of NATO
personally I don't see how the countries
that had been under the uh the Domino
and the occupation of of Russia could
have desired anything less than
adjoining NATO but it's true that at the
same time this enlargement of NATO it it
looked at Russia no there was a
partnership there were all sorts of
Institutions created to try to to a
Syria Russia but at the end of the day
NATO was never going to be seen as a
friendly organization from Russia there
was the political issue the the back and
forth who's coming into NATO
should Poland come into NATO should
Ukraine come into NATO and there were
people pushing for this very hard
um I will confess that at the time I
felt a little ambivalent not ambivalent
not that's not right I felt uh that we
should be very cautious and not just
Stampede into something because it was
something that felt good to us and we
wanted to help our friends in the East
but we needed to be sensitive to history
so we have all kinds of things through
history that have helped us to come
together
but we still have divisive things
underneath
we also have a very very short memory
in my opinion very short memory for the
tragedies that you gave us an example of
this morning
of what happens in wars and as someone
who has spent uh I think too much time
involved in conflicts around this world
it is not something that we should wish
to have repeated and yet we seem to just
go at it again and again
and we are not in my opinion learning
the basic lessons that we should have
learned from the past
we should know that human nature is
going to do what it does and you have to
work at it it isn't going to be
just go away so if we recognize that
these Tendencies are still inside of us
how do we bring out the better
Tendencies I mean we have an amazing
capacity for goodness in the world and
we see that every day
but there's this constant battle if you
would between the the good and the evil
that hasn't gone away and we continue in
my opinion to make this mistake of
getting into conflict that at the end of
the day is ugly
all the way through but we forget about
it very quickly and we seem to just move
on and and we find ourselves not
learning the lessons of history and I
think that's one of the most important
things we should take away and try to
get our young people to understand I
believe that most of Europe did draw
lessons from World War one and World War
II
um which is why uh War Among Us in the
European Union and NATO is Unthinkable
you know I served the European
Parliament from here I'll go to
Strasbourg uh which started Life as
argentorum a Roman outpost on the Rhine
it was defending the Latin World against
the Germanic world and you know after
2000 years of Wars it's still in the
same place the border and we've drawn
the lesson that pooling some aspects of
sovereignty is better than worrying